holy crap guys we just had the most
successful charity livestream we've ever
had in our year of doing these live
streams we raised and this is just an
estimate but we think we raised forty
four thousand nine hundred and fifty
dollars for charity
now that's an early estimate but Wow
that completely smashes our previous
record of $26,000 just last month for
Cincinnati Children's Hospital and this
forty five thousand dollars was raised
in one day one day we managed to do this
that is absolutely incredible
thank you guys sincerely so much for
helping out you guys do not know how
much of a difference you have made and
this is all going to bestfriends dork
and sincerely guys thank you so much if
you didn't know we were selling these
one-day special edition versions of this
shirt and they had the that they have
this they have it special they have this
special heart on the sleeve that's only
available for this charity livestream
that says mark flyers heroes and you
definitely earn that name you guys are
heroes through and through for
everything that you've done but however
there is one caveat
I feel a little bad because yesterday I
went out and I got a little excited I
went on Facebook and Twitter I told you
guys a number of shirts that we thought
we sold but that was an early estimate
now the $45,000 I don't make a penny off
of remember this this all goes directly
to the charity but the number that I
told you guys gave people a wrong idea
how much money was raised that kind of
overshot this early estimate now I'll
find out how much exactly we raised by
the end of the week but I still feel bad
because I don't want to betray you guys
it's trust and I don't want anyone out
there to get the wrong idea that I'm
skimming off the surf viscera I'm taking
a cut because I am NOT I'm not taking a
penny off of this only the money that
goes towards the production cost and the
company is is what is taken away from
this every other penny goes towards the
charity but I still may I still feel bad
because I don't want people to get the
wrong idea your trust is so important to
me in this thing so to try to make it up
for you I will also be making a personal
contribution of $2,000 in addition to
the $45,000 that you guys raised through
the shirt sales and also on top of that
I will be ordering an additional 30
shirts and I will be sending it to kids
in the Cincinnati Children's Hospital so
that they can be a hero too and have a
shirt for them that was an agreement
that we made at the end of the live
stream I wanted to do a giveaway but
there were so many people in the stream
that I didn't know how to make it fair
and I obviously couldn't give everyone a
shirt so this was kind of a compromise
for the best of both worlds so even
though I may feel bad you guys should
not you have done an incredible thing
absolutely amazing good that you have
done and I am so grateful that you guys
believe in me I I can't even imagine
that we would have been here a year ago
I mean I think in the charity last room
we did a year ago we raised maybe $2,000
and to go from that to $45,000 it is
it's just unbelievable to me and I am so
grateful that you guys are here
supporting me sincerely thank you from
the bottom of my heart I mean this
channel that we've been building is
growing astronomically and it's all
thanks to you guys
sincerely this channel would not grow if
it wasn't you spreading the word about
it sharing videos with friends is one
thing but also spreading the message of
the good that we do through these
charity livestreams is even more
important to me so please keep doing it
keep it up because for every new person
that gets in here is more good that we
can do for these charities so please
spread the word don't just tell them
about the videos that I make that are
kind of funny I mean do that if it helps
it out but really tell them about the
good that we have done because this
community that we have been building in
this community that we have here it is
more important to me than anything I've
ever done and that's why this trust
between us is so important and that's
why I want you guys to believe in me and
believe that I am 100% committed to
doing good for the world and I don't
want like anything for myself I want to
give as much as possible and I'm so glad
that you guys want to give too because
this is the kind of stuff that is going
to change the world I mean a year ago
some people are skeptical that we were
actually doing any good but now it
cannot be denied how much good we're
doing so sincerely from the bottom of my
heart thank you guys so much for
everything that you've done and thank
you so much for believing me please
continue to go out and tell people about
this and what we do here and we will
create something absolutely incredible I
can't wait to see what we do a year from
today so sincerely thank you guys so
much for watching thank you so much for
donating and thank you so much for
believing and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye bye bye bye
bye
[Music]
you